hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now this is the first episode that I've
recorded since I dyed my hair this
lovely shade of pink and it's still a
little disconcerting to see myself in
the webcam that handsome devil over
there is almost too distracting but this
is game this game has been updated many
times since the last time that it played
it there's a lot of new stuff to do
there's a lot of serie game modes and in
fact there's a lot of stuff that people
discovered that I did not the last time
that I was playing it so without further
ado I'm going to get started and the
newness starts out with the ability to
customize your incredibly luxuriously
handsome senpai who seems to be naked in
a cloud setting of some sort anyway so
you can adjust the skin color of
whatever that's good enough for me
standard is fine this hair looks good oh
no way that hair looks good beautiful
he's glorious that's my senpai forever
oh my God he's you're gonna need a
bigger cloud than that for my senpai if
you know what I'm talking about oh god
oh god well I mean he kind of just
reiterated everything that I've said in
the past few episodes but I think I said
it a little Oh
oh okay so apparently that you can go
into town that's cool whoa what the hell
I'd
[Music]
oh hey hey wait a minute if you get
stuck okay oh cool
great glad that's the thing okay I have
okay well that Jesus shouldn't have gone
off the road I guess oh is that a
barrier you think that's gonna stop me
huh a little tiny baby panda bear oh
that's cool
okay thank you thank you thank you okay
why why was that even a thing
hello okay cool great okay
so with the updates to this game still
weird for me to have pink hair when I
look up there but for the updates to
this game they added in a few things
they had a shower room over there they
had something to the gym I have no idea
and they had a little more to the school
so when everyone's gonna be rolling in
here I'm gonna find out the more stuff
to do hello stupid oh god that
oh that's senpai 3 jeez I'm so sorry you
a Sun and a genie you you you you
usually you're the reason why I was
doing this you you you hey you hey you
hey hi hi hey hey hey hey you yo PPO sue
that might be info Chan have no idea
maybe it is anyway hey hey hey you hey
hey you hey hey hey oh come on just cuz
it actually doesn't have a panty shot in
it doesn't mean that was not legitimate
you shut your mouth yeah yes excellent
now I have a picture of PPO shoes oh my
god PPO shoes Fannie's I owe you a favor
for this and do you do you now really
really is that the case anyway PPO sue
you have the same hair color as me am do
we're like twinsies it's a nun the game
in real life don't you want to talk to
me don't you want to be my friend don't
you want to be my friend don't you want
to go just chose me
hi hey baby I'll do maybe I'll go peepee
hey booboo baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby baby other baby other I know you're
all gonna be so curious anyway about the
showers yes you can get naked in the
showers but it's not the type of naked
you're thinking about it's kind of the
heavenly cloud to everything blocking
everything naked type of thing maybe I
will love me well I'm negative
baby thereby see I got a bad case of
cloud but going on
and also a bad case of cloud boob wait
oh hey wait Sam by sample I don't really
notice me wait I don't I please senpai
senpai will you let me know wait sorry I
don't you like that side bite huh I'm
naked with weird clouds coming out of my
body tonight is this attractive J oh
yeah only a little strange don't mind me
not strange at all hey if you keep an
open mind about things nude is the way
to be okay forget about that that's
enough of that
anyway those other things that I wanted
to do Hank's my favorite I like how my
pigtails are resting on my boobs really
convenient about that hello fellow
classmates it's an excellent day at
school time anybody bothered by any of
this no no one at all no one's weirded
out I'm just one of the girls here don't
mind me I'm not weird is this what we're
doing is this what girls do I know you
are you bothered by my nudity cuz no one
else seems to be why don't you work why
don't you do nothing are you just
another fakie fakie like the one
downstairs by the tree I guess no one's
bothered by me being naked which means
that I can just wander around everywhere
naked sure there was something else
someone said something about the
third-floor bathroom in the girls
bathroom this one's dark good thing I
got my Chloe boobs
Chloe glowing boobs lose something
spooky scary in here
oh hey whoa that's actually kind of
creepy where'd you go oh oh oh hey
you're just in Vista oh that's weird
oh that's weird oh that's so weird oh
that's really weird oh that's so weird
okay so anyway that's that glad I did
that now I'm a little creeped out now
but Oh Peter there you are are you in
Foshan
never mind then good God
okay so now there's another option here
that I did not explore which is the
Easter Egg menu which I had no idea
about but this is where everyone look
cuz I knew that other people were making
them go into Titan mode by had no idea
what those mean so either these wait to
deactivate an Easter Egg you'll have to
research the day using the tilde key
okay so each of these shows a different
type of thing you can do punished mode
is also I was warned that each of these
modes have their own copyrighted music
so you'll hear everything being replaced
I'm pretty sure this is a metal gear
thing right that's what this is right it
can't be anything else right because
this must it yeah it's metal gear
because I still haven't played Metal
Gear 5 the phantom pain because I just
haven't had an opportunity to Nexis
slender mode whoa oh crap whoa whoa
holy crap do my boobs still grow they do
they do
slender boobs going on up here holy crap
that's so scary
can I still get
[Laughter]
Oh oh sorry sorry you get away from me
I don't know if I meant it there's my
crotch apparently still floating in
mid-air the slender woman there's
probably some anime reference that I'm
not gonna get look at me posing all cool
and kind of stupid what the hell is this
fear me for some strange reason whoa oh
god I can't wait to see everybody oh wow
Oh senpai you're looking normal said why
oh I'm the only one that's like this why
am I the only one hey hey hey handcuff
me senpai I just want you to wrap me up
okay bye hello now you shall pay yeah
your boobs are big but look at my arms
and head and also everything else about
me I'm gonna get naked just because I
feel like it I don't know what this is
gonna look like okay here we go
oh god it's miss shapen and odd it's
almost scarier than the Slenderman
version I should have gotten Slenderman
naked
wow that's a statement I never thought
I'd say it's odd when the weirdest thing
isn't the boobs growing back and forth
oh well where's all trying to keep
things a little bit proportion here
aren't we just going to be the best
friends I've ever had have urban never
never
I've made changes for you I've made
changes for our lives I've made it so
that we can read together finally this
is what you always wanted bigger is
always better
you know what I say hey baby are you
doing oh man I know I'm so perfect now
write everything about me is did the
path
she's acting strange oh maybe not you
know you could probably love me it's
gonna be okay yeah but kind of cool
right to kind of hot it strains big
armed way she's starting to freak me a
freak how dare you how dare you oh there
that's really creepy
leave me alone what did I do no way oh
my god that's so terrifying oh man okay
fine then again yep pretty much
you can never face the rest of humanity
again either okay okay I think I'm done
for this episode but I'm gonna pick it
up in another one and then check out
titan mode and a lot of the other cool
game mechanics that were added because
there was a lot of stuff added but I'm
out of time for this one and I'm out of
sanity for this one too so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the MJ support videos that I've done
check out the other versions of um very
similar that I played in the past and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
don't notice me right now oh hi senpai
house